all right I am posting pictures to my
Instagram account with some frequency
David Pakman on Instagram will look at
some of the more popular pictures that I
posted number one it actually snowed in
Boston Pat and we've been talking about
this lack of snow in Boston over the
last year or two I missed like the major
snow year two years ago and one of the
most popular pictures that I posted to
Instagram this week was me with just
proof that it was snowing behind us and
yeah I mean that's snow Rachael right I
mean I don't know what else to say yeah
I don't I don't know if the popularity
was due to this snow oh yeah or just
that weird look on my face no I don't
think it's not a weird look I just think
there's um the facial recognition
technology yeah you can put in your
photo and it will highlight which parts
of your picture are the most memorable
due to the the algorithm that they wrote
in most photos that do have a physical
human face tend to be more popular than
those without I do notice that the
pictures were I'm in the pictures I am
in do better on Instagram than pictures
of like you know I had it out with that
I'm not it I guess I'm saying that of
course more generally because if you
have some sort of landscape from the
National Geographic sure we're gonna do
better than a picture of my face but I
don't know if I agree with Rachael on
this one I think it has to do with your
facial expression and you do yeah it was
right know what's on purpose about that
that's the way I look when I'm not in
the studio alright instant chaos in my
neighborhood by the way from this snow
storm I can only imagine what it was
like two years ago there was like four
inches of snow and all of a sudden no
one can park no one can drive
everybody's snowed in and I'm glad I
missed the two year ago snowpocalypse I
can't imagine also because there's the
the unwritten rules of parking yeah
Southie where if if someone is you're
worried someone's going to get in your
parking spot just put an old bench there
I mean even the concept of your parking
spot isn't saying rachel's talking about
street parking where there was this
thing during snowpocalypse two years ago
where if you put like a chair there
you're basically saying I'm holding this
spot and if someone took your spot again
all unwritten rules it was sort of
expected that your car would be keyed
when you came back it's it's like the
Wild West for parking in South Boston
yeah it's really not a great idea to
take someone else's parking space even
though they really have no right to it
none whatsoever thing could happen yeah
and the most popular picture on my
Instagram account before you put it up
pat I'll let Rachel know there's been
this thing people leaving voicemails
calling for pictures of me shirtless and
the funny thing is it happened a while
ago and I participated in throwback
Thursday which I know you're incredibly
familiar with rachel which is when on
thursdays on instagram you post an old
picture and i posted the following
picture from when I was on a Spanish
island vacationing and as you can attest
I'm not wearing a shirt in this picture
it is by its very nature a shirtless
picture yeah they should probably put
that in like men's health or something
right yeah not not necessarily the
picture of hell I don't really know but
what do you think about this picture Pat
I mean finally the moment has come we've
all been waiting yeah right and now we
have a chance to see Pat and I were
waiting for quite some time and I'm
really thankful that it's happened all
right well it's there i'm on instagram
at david pakman follow me there a lot of
stuff i'm only posting to Instagram
these days why I have no idea I guess
just lack of knowledge about social
media
probably because you're not a millennial
oh we're not opening a door up again
yeah let's move on I really don't like
when you do that we know that I am a
millennial that back tonight I looked it
up afterwards I back to 1980 Pat why am
I talking to pat pat pat agrees with you
anyone said you weren't going to open up
that can of worms and then you start
digging into it